[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show my
name's Paul and I think that aliens is
probably up there on the Mount Rushmore
of the best sequels ever made though
this leans far more into being an action
movie than the prior entry it feels like
an evolution of what came before and it
builds naturally on character arcs the
xenomorph's backstory man everything
that made that first film a masterpiece
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the movie and going over
the themes hidden details Easter eggs
and things you may have missed now
whereas Ridley Scott said that he
actually preferred his original version
of the film James Cameron has said that
the aliens directors cut is his
preferred version of the movie I
actually prefer this version to the
release version because I think as it's
been best described by one of my friends
it's 40 miles of bad Road I think it's a
longer more intense and more suspenseful
version of the film now this is the
version I'm going to be going over for
this video and if you haven't seen it
then I'd definitely recommend that you
watch it over the theatrical aliens is a
far more faster and intense story than
its predecessor and this is even shown
from the early title reveal which
happens way quicker than it did in the
prior movie The Story itself features
the archetype of Joseph Campbell's
Heroes Jenny and in case you're unaware
of what this is it basically provides an
outline of a typical hero's journey
obviously now this starts off with a
call to action which is Ripley being
asked to go back to lv426 we then have a
refusal like what can be seen in the
film The Ada Mentor can be initially
seen as Carter Burke and then from here
we cross the threshold when going to the
planet new allies and enemies are made
in the Marines and nude before we get an
ordeal in which they discover the
Xenomorphs from here we have the death
of a mentor battle with the brother
which could represent Burke and so on
and so forth now another evolution in
the themes is seen in the reoccurring
motifs centered around motherhood in our
alien breakdown we discussed how
childbirth was something that reoccurred
throughout and this was seen in how the
crew were framed when they woke up this
was then carried across to the eggs
chess best sister and even the alien
being ejected into space has been
thought of as being a baby exiting the
womb with umbilical cord being cut now
the Harpoon Gun that provided that chord
in the film actually returns early on in
the movie and when we first gone
Ripley's ship you can see where the gun
got stuck in the door at the end of the
last movie now the motherhood in this
film is very much felt within Ripley's
character Rock in the extended edition
we see her daughter Amanda oh yeah
actually play as in the seminal alien
isolation Ripley learns that Amanda died
whilst she was out in space and she very
much becomes a surrogate mother to Newt
this is reflected in the final scene of
the movie which has Ripley looking of a
nude as they both sleep in stasis pods
Cameron beautifully Bells upon the
ending of the Past film and that too
closed out on a shot of Ripley in a pod
mirroring what happens yeah the big bad
of this movie is awesome of the two with
the alien queen being at the heart of
the film as she protects her own
children just like how Ripley does now
if you want to see the scene with Amanda
then you have to watch the director's
cut and she was actually played by
sigourney's real-life Mother Elizabeth
though this has never been out now
confirmed it was said that Sigourney was
pretty annoyed that the studio made
Cameron cut so many scenes from the film
including this one sent it around
motherhood according to the reports Fox
wanted Sigourney back for Alien 3 but it
said that she refused to do it however
they did gain some good will by saying
they'd really set director's cut with
the deleted scenes back in the
theatrical release was dropped in 1986
and by 87 they were working on the
special edition which was aired on CBS
in 1989. directors cuts are a lot more
common these days but back then this was
a big deal and we all know that Weaver
of course came back for alien 3. now as
for this movie itself discussions about
a sequel happened right after the
release of the first movie but the
reason it took seven years to make was
because Fox didn't actually believe
there was enough interest to Warren the
follow-up they actually thought that the
first film was a fluke and due to
declining box office returns with
Horrors it did get shelled the
production company for the first film
Brandywine still came up with ideas
though and these range from things like
a ship binding the alien out in space to
Jones the cat being a carrier so yes one
of the ideas was that there was going to
be a face hooker on the ship and then
attached to the cat now these all got
scrapped obviously but there was an idea
that stuck and this was that the film
was gonna center around the military
well James Cameron had actually been
working alongside Sylvester still on on
Rambo 2 and together they were the ones
who turned in the final draft Cameron
also had a screenplay floating around
for a little film that you might have
heard about which was called The
Terminator blown away by this script
Brandywine asked Cameron to do a
treatment of quote-unquote Ripley and
soldiers which Cameron wrote over three
days strangely enough they didn't
actually want Ridley Scott to return as
a director and on top of this they never
pegged Cameron for it either I bet
things sort of fell into place and the
reason why the movie took so long to
release was because they were beholding
the Cameron work on Terminator whilst
this was on the back foot I'm not going
to get too much into it but there was a
lot of distrust around Cameron initially
Judas got being British and Cameron
being Canadian there was also lots of
argument on set too with a spritz
demanding tea breaks which Cameron got
annoyed about at the point that he
apparently smashed a tea card like it
was the like button oh the humanity not
not RT several people were also fired
including the Director of Photography
who didn't like things the way the
Cameron wanted and also James Remar who
was initially cast as Hicks caught with
drugs he was kicked out of the cast
though some of the shots of Hicks from
behind are actually Remar in the helmet
Sigourney Weaver also didn't sign on
until three months before the project
was due to start and she brought with
her a number of Demands these included
and I [__] you're not there were to be
no guns in the movie she would have sex
with her alien and she was going to die
at the end Sigourney Weaver's a strong
anti-gun advocate so she didn't want any
weapons like that which is crazy when
you think about this movie but Cameron
talked her out of that and the other two
things she wanted interestingly when she
became a producer on Alien 3 in
Resurrection these did end up happening
which yeah maybe Cameron was right but
how did he get her to agree to it well
one million dollars which in the 80s was
the biggest payday an actress had ever
received compare this to the first film
where she was paid 35 000 and you can
see how much of an increase that this
was now much like the first film we all
been in space with the narcissist slowly
drifting towards the camera this is
named after the ship from the Joseph
Conrad novel Children of the sea which
is a book about isolation and also
loneliness the nostroma was also named
that Conrad came up with and keeping in
line with this the soloko was the name
of the town at the events of that novel
played out in now we catch a frozen
vessel blanketed in ice giving off a
cold feeling that's instantly
juxtapowers by the burning heat of the
door being cut open in our alien
breakdown we talked about how the
xenomorph was brought into the design of
the environment and this is shown at
several points in that film yeah it's
very much present with the Drone coming
in too and we see it has a long black
head and also pipes on the side evoking
the xenomorph's tail Cameron actually
turned down H.R Geiger working on this
movie which he since admitted was due to
how arrogant he was he clearly regrets
it but I do think that a lot of the
designs in this film work really well on
their own unless it scans the room we
can see several items which carry over
from the first film including the helmet
that Ripley wore at the end a very much
meant to feel detached from this
futuristic world and as a salvage team
enter they're almost like aliens
themselves with their futuristic Tekken
spacesuits to compare it to another film
I think this is like when Marty first
travels back to 1955 in Back to the
Future he scares the Pea bodies due to
how he looks and it's very much carried
across into these spacesuits as well now
alien had this almost VHS quality to it
with the technology whereas here it's
highly Advanced letting us know this is
beyond what we've seen before we also
hear someone say buy a readouts are all
on the green looks like she's alive and
this is actually the voice of James
Cameron doing a vocal Cameo and
providing the film with its first lines
of dialogue and from here we cut to
Ripley on Gateway station which is when
she's visited by Coda Burke we learned
that it's been 57 years as opposed to
the six weeks that she initially thought
she'd be out there in the first film I
think something that Cameron does
brilliantly is that he doesn't fall into
the Trap that a lot of sequels do they
tend to just remake and rehash elements
of the original whereas here he throws a
curveball like this early on in order to
completely Place her in a new alien
surrounding that she won't really
recognize had the cat in space or egg
thing happen then we likely would have
got the Beats of the first movie and
this is what I've ding films like the
thing prequel for doing as it's not
really that creative however this allows
him to take things in a New Direction
and of all the character in several new
ways this sets her into a panic and it's
revealed that this is a dream sequence
in which Ripley believes that she has a
chest burster inside of her Jonesy
hisses and this of course calls back to
the first film when the animal did the
same thing with the xenomorph Ripley
utters the words
and this is a callback that the
directors could have alien in which
Dallas said the same thing
now though this is somewhat decanonized
Cameron did take the idea of it and
integrated into aliens with people being
stuck into walls he also borrowed from
Dallas saying kill me and had the woman
that we come across saying you're gonna
be all right
just stay calm now one of the film's
themes is set up here and huge announced
to Rob AJ for pointing out the
differences and similarities between the
two movies alien was very much a
physical battle against the alien
whereas aliens is a psychological one
Ripley is racked with nightmares but her
sleeping soundly at the end next to nude
shows how she's overcome this now we
could to her sat on a park bench but
this is later revealed to just be a
projection it shows the world that
Ripley once knew is gone and just
something that's archived in recordings
and also photographs originally we
weren't meant to see this flecker I like
how it is here and then we're gonna have
Jones try and jump at a bird smack into
the wall and then reveal it was fake now
this idea of the past just being an
image is followed up by her learning
what happened to her daughter which is
too shoners of photo this highlights
that the past is now gone and it truly
plans Ripley as being on her own her and
you share a lot of common ground and
they're both people who've lost their
families due to encounters with his
Xenomorphs now the noble adds a line
about how she died of cancer and there's
also a bit about how the Black Box on
the narcissist was broken suggesting
that someone tampered with it to destroy
evidence before the hearing I wonder who
that could be now from here we could
have that hearing and learn that they've
been there for three hours Ripley is
desperately trying to tell the company
about the horrors that they faced but
they just see numbers in dollar signs
some aren't even listening to her and we
could catch someone on the left sitting
sketching away as the camera pans we can
also catch a man on the right doing a
crossword on his lap and they completely
Switched Off to exactly what she's
saying in the background we can also
catch the crew from the first movie
along with their biographies there's
some really interesting details on them
and for Dallas we can see that he worked
as a former employee for the Tyrell
Corporation this is the company from
Blade Runner which is a nice little nod
to Ridley Scott we also have Lambert and
viewed in isolation a buyer says that
she was born a man and is trans Ripley
it's frustrated and loses it and we
learned that her license has been
suspended by the company now though she
doesn't get fined for blowing the ship
she won't have the career that she once
had we learned that lv46 isn't seen as
being hostile because terraformers are
already there and one of the big
criticisms around the film is how they
didn't discover the engineer ship
earlier in Cameron's original script and
he actually did have machines that hit
the planet first and these
centerraformed it before the humans
arrived this actually buried the alien
vessel and it stopped the SOS from
getting out which is why it was never
picked up and we see Hadley's helps
being set up there with a colony of 158
people yeah we meet Mac McDonald playing
the character Al in the first episode of
Red Dwarf would have him giving some
other note to this as he played the
captain of a doom mining vessel now we
discovered that Burke actually sent a
message out there asking them to go and
investigate the grid coordinates for
where the engineer ship was and this
adds an extra layer of subtext to him
just like how the company sent Ash out
on the Nostromo Burke was clearly after
the money and didn't care about killing
people to get it it's kind of
heartbreaking seeing kids playing in the
hall in the very same scene and
originally nude was supposed to be a
part of this later on we learned that
she survived for seven months out there
on her own and this was through hiding
in the vents in recesses there was a bit
of an added character-backed story in
the original script and there were
versions where she was playing it with
the kids at this point Newt was the best
at it on the entire station and she even
got the nickname new in in reference to
the little reptile because she could fit
into places so the kids couldn't now for
the final version they ended up removing
that but we do get a line from her
brother that gives a note to this
YouTube You're Going Places we can't fit
why
why oh
I catch either of you playing in the air
just again I'll turn your high now news
by Carrie Hawn and to make this scene a
bit easier on her her brother is played
by her real life one we watch as a dad
discovers the ship from the first film
and this had still been kept in storage
behind the scenes so Cameron was able to
eat Liza on set who wants more get this
anymore of design brought into the
location and inside the ship we catch
the bone-like structures on the wall
which later resemble the limbs of the
alien queen the Facehugger wants more
returns and Newt scream gets drowned out
possibly time back to the film's tagline
that is in space no one can hear you you
scream which is a bit of a reach
now from here we jump back to Ripley and
he's cut her hair and is donning a white
T-shirt this is something that Scott
himself later paid tribute to an alien
Covenant and Daniels at one point looks
like she's cosplaying as the character
Ripley is smoking the longest cigarette
you've ever seen and this is just ash
who she beat in the first film mate
why is that all well she's very burnt
out at this point but is still hanging
on however it's also used to set up
somewhat of a narrative device later on
as she uses a lighter to set up the
sprinklers in Hadley's hope had she not
been smoking then people might be like
why is she carrying around a lighter so
I like how Cameron at least gave a
reason for that Albert comes to her home
and we also meet Lieutenant Gordon he's
got a badge with uscm on his arm which
stands for United States colonial
Marines the United States Marines badge
is a golden eagle Standing On Top of the
earth however now that we've conquered
the planet it's swooping down on them in
the film we discover that Gorman's
extremely inexperienced and this is why
none of the Marines respect him how many
drops is this for you lieutenant
simulated now the book actually adds
some extra reasoning to this and we
discovered that Burke picked him because
he'd be easier to manipulate inside
Carter also talks about how the
corporation is building better worlds
which calls back to the tagline on the
Weyland yutani sign it's all prbs and
they just care about colonizing planets
and making weapons it's a really sleazy
way to get Ripley involved and he tries
to sell her on how much of an
opportunity that it is he also calls her
kiddo come on that's a second chance
kill and polarizer also plays Dr Owens
in stranger things and he refers to 11
as kiddo at several points whatever you
want Kiddo it's on me now he brings up
the Marines and talks about how state of
the art they are these colonial Marines
are very tough arm Brazen they're
packing state-of-the-art Firepower
there's nothing they can handle this is
being talked about in a number of videos
on this film but Cameron stated that he
had lots of metaphors for the Vietnam
War placed within this movie as we
mentioned earlier he was a big part of
Rambo 2 and this clearly leaped into his
mind when making this film Cameron said
that the film can be seen as an allegory
to the inability of the superior
American Firepower to conquer the Unseen
enemy located in Vietnam he later state
that they represented a lot of fire and
very little wisdom Cameron modeled the
Marines and how soldiers appeared in
movies with them being overtly masculine
even down to Vasquez Vasquez
have you ever been mistaken for a man no
have you the Dropship was based on an
Apache helicopter and Cameron also had
the actors personalize their own suits
of armor similar to soldiers in Vietnam
Hudson has the word Louise written on
his which is a nod to Bill Paxton's real
wife along with several other things we
can catch a calendar on his helmet and
this shows that he has just one month
left in service later on he mentions
just having four weeks left oh man I was
getting short four more weeks and out we
can also see the word game over which
the character of course says in the
movie in the best line ever game over
man this game over what the [__] are we
gonna do now Cameron gave the impression
that Hudson's very much meant to
represent the Marine mine State and when
he thinks he has an easy target he's
overconfident in talking trash however
when he's actually in danger he turns
into a complete coward and isn't
opposite to how he comes across when he
thinks he has the upper hand I actually
got my hands on a master class
membership to see Cameron talking about
some of the scenes and he did say he
regretted how he portrayed Marines in
this movie he said he had a brother that
served in them for six years and if he
was to do this again then they'd have
been the complete opposite to how they
are here he said as a filmmaker you
learn and grow and then he has nothing
but respect for the Marines now unless
you watch Avatar now Cameron also
predicted the video phone and we see
Carter's analysis of Ripley coming true
I've read it you wake up every night
your sheets are soaking I said no I love
how she grabs her chest in this moment
and it instantly tells you exactly
what's happened in her nightmare Mercury
assures her that they're going out there
to destroy the creatures but we learn
that was a [__] lie and the first
film had a lot of talks about shares and
money and this is once more murdenberg
the reason that he doesn't go out there
with another company man is that he'd
have to split the discovery with them so
he's on his own for his own ends we then
cut to space and we see the solaco which
itself looks like a gun cutting through
the cosmos echoing the opening of alien
we move through the ship and see it on
display Really Scott used this to great
effect in the first film and it made the
audience take on this voyeuristic point
of view as we travel through the long
corridors we saw two nodding Birds on a
table and Cameron somewhat mimics this
by having two spinning table things as
we travel through the ship to table
spinning things I don't think that's
what they called but you know what I
mean don't you don't be a dick in the
comments what you mean written it you
son of a [__] at this point we go to
the stasis pods which align an entire
wall a little bit of movie Magic here
and the team didn't want to waste money
building all these pods so they just
made five of them and then placed a
mirror on the end wall if you look
closely at it you can kind of tell it's
a mirror but it gives the impression
that the ships much larger than it
actually is we see the computer start up
and this mimics the opening of the first
film in which the machines turned on we
then get a list of all the Chrome board
and their initials Gorman is amongst
these and he's the only Marine to have
their first name said because they don't
respect him and he doesn't fit in he can
really feel the camaraderie in these
moments so and that's actually for a
good reason Cameron filmed the movie out
of order with this being one of the last
scenes they shot and this is because he
wanted to build the relationships on set
so that they felt authentic when we got
to this point we then get more Vietnam
imagery with the cigar chomping Sergeant
napone the dark green clothes that are
reminiscent of jungle wear but later
wears a red bandana and the pilot wears
aviators evoking imagery of that era who
then see Vasquez doing chin-ups and this
is alongside her buddy private Drake
this is where we get the mistaken for a
manline this actually pulls from an
interview with a 1930s actress that was
Talala Bankhead and a newspaper
columnist asked her if she'd ever been
mistaken for one but she replied no
darling have you
foreign
was obviously a massive fan and
throughout a lot of his work he has
these strong female characters who don't
take no sh now after owning Hudson they
do a special handshake which shows their
friendship this actually happens later
on in the movie too when Vasquez dies
alongside Gorman though she initially
doesn't respect him in the film she does
at the end and this is to show that he's
now one of them in the end he did get to
die in Avenger and they also bring up
the fact that several of the planets
have been colonized sure wouldn't mind
getting some more of that arcturian boom
thing remember that time yeah the one
that you had was male
now it shows that there are other
planets out there populated with humans
which ties back to the building better
world's tagline but those arturians sure
sound better God damn I've also seen
readings of this tying in with the
Lambert reveal from before along with
the common on Vasquez being mistaken for
a man people have said that the show's
gender is far more fluid in the future
but I don't know if that's been
retroactively added in to give it a more
modern mindset you'd have to ask Cameron
himself whether those lines all tied
together or not but it is interesting
how they do keep repeating anyway at
this point Bishop does the knife in
fingers trick which I must have tried to
do about 40 times when I was a teenager
actually got pretty good at it too
because I was really skilled with my
right hand around those days
this was achieved pretty simply and they
just sped up the footage which you can
kind of tell if you keep an eye on Drake
and how fast that is head moves now
Bishop at this point is revealed to be
an Android which freaks Ripley out she
of course had a major running with Ash
during the first film and and similar to
him milky white substance leaks out of a
cut on his finger Androids are also
meant to be infallible but we see here
that Bishop has missed and cut himself
this is obviously worrying and it's
meant to be a red herring in the movie
that Ripley eventually learns to trust
okay she missed our last video as well
the Android's name is sent through the
alphabet as they appear in the franchise
we had a for ash B for Bishop C for call
and then D for David now the robot being
bad in the first film and then good in
the second is something that Cameron
ended up repeating and he of course did
the same thing with his two Terminator
movies we find out that older models are
Twitchy and that since then they've had
behavioral Inhibitors put in place
however to me this shows that the
company just don't really care and that
though they fix the Androids they're
still happy sending people to their
deaths we get some hilarious lines here
with Hicks busting loads of jokes what
is it Hicks Hudson sir
he's Hicks sorry Hudson and I remember
even back in the day everyone's still
got those two names confused right right
somebody said alien she thought they
said illegal alien signed up
we also see that Marines are so sure in
their methods that it's become almost
like a shooting gallery for them to go
on these missions I only need to know
one thing
where they are now if you pay close
attention takes during this you can
actually see him Madding her words
showing how many times they've gone
through this I need to know one
where they are Jay gorser has riding on
his cat which was to reference in the
helmets of Full Metal Jacket as
something that soldiers did in Vietnam
up until his point Ripley was seen as
being one of the corporate heads on the
mission and she wasn't really respected
whether she gets her hands dirty and
helps out by using the power loader in
the bay this of course foreshadows how
she fights the queen later on and it's
such a cool bit of armat that really
adds to the battle initially it was
supposed to be a four-legged thing but
Cameron saw the 8080s and Empire Strikes
Back and felt it would be too similar
however the quadrupled rendition appears
in the novelization in the movie which
also has some other notable differences
the alien queen in that has small albino
drones surrounding her and these smooth
the eggs after they're late these
completely ignore Ripley and they just
go about their business like drones do
in a beehive anyway Cameron originally
just wanted to use stop motion for the
power loader but this proved to be
expensive and thus they used Rod puppets
instead 5p people had to operate this
and mannequins are Ripley were also used
to make it seem like someone was in the
machine now during the scene in which we
see Ripley moving stuff about you can
catch another machine being upright
behind her if you zoom in on it you can
actually see that this is the mannequin
and this is the same one that was used
for Ripley it's just dressed in military
uniform now there's so many cool
movements as they move in like Vasquez
and Drake moving their guns about and we
see adios written on hurts and tush
written on his the Dropship pilot
Colette also has fly the friendly skies
on her helmet and this was a slogan used
by Delta Airlines in the 80s on the ship
itself we can also see a sticker that
says Bug Stomper with attack line we
endanger species now the term burcon
appears earlier in the movie during the
briefing scene and we also get lines
about there being a xenomorph all we
know is that there's still no contact
with the colony and the xenomorph may be
involved
because of this people have theorized
that they'd run into Xenomorphs before
which kind of contradicts how surprised
they are later on in the movie however
the website asked technica.com explained
that this is simply a play on the term
snipunt which means basically a task in
which they can shoot from afar without
getting their hands dirty bugs as a term
used to describe all extraterrestrial
life and when terraforming a planet it'd
probably be life-forms and creatures
that they'd have to kill first in order
to clear out the area now we watch them
getting ready and vasquez's armor says
elrice cmpv which have pronounced right
my Spanish is second to none either way
this this means the risk always lives
and it was later used in light years an
inscription on Derek's outer panel
described as an Express Elevator to hell
we see the Dropship scene play out with
the Marines being excited at the
prospect of having some fun it shows
they're hubris and we even get Hicks to
sleep which cements how little worry
they have about this I am the ultimate
such a good little bit of acting here by
belpuck and as the ship shakes we see
him drop his guards slightly in show a
slight bit of beer on his face as he
reaches out to hold something drop ships
are of course also used in Vietnam and
throughout Warfare situations to get
soldiers in quickly Steven Spielberg
brilliantly recaptured missions like
this in the opening of Saving Private
Ryan but whereas that was a wash with
fear these marines are overly confident
don't worry
me and my squad of ultimate badasses
will protect you Cameron beautifully
laces tension throughout the scene as we
sense something is off though and we
can't share the confidence that the
Marines have where's the damn Beacon
oh I see it
now from the skies they Patrol the base
and we see how the biomechanical design
of the alien's tail has been integrated
once more into pipes that line the
facility the Marines then move in and
they approach Hadley's hope which they
find eerily abandoned no music is used
in these moments and instead we get near
silence as they Patrol the insights
Cameron's directing here makes it so
tense and for a lot of this scene we
have the cameras punted at the Marines
instead of what they're looking at
psychologically this creates the feeling
of tension as well looking at them and
unaware of what they're able to see when
we do good at that point of view it's
through their grainy camera which again
adds this idea that we as an audience
don't know what's going on eventually
they pick up something on the motion
detector and they end up moving into a
room so far there haven't been any
bodies because all the people here have
been taken off and used as hosts for the
pace Huggers however just before they go
into the room we catch a bloody
handprint hinting that something bad
happened here it's an animal fake out
with some little hamsters and Ridley
Scott did something similar with Jonesy
in the first film he then passed to some
holes running through the hull and as we
learned an alien his xenomorph's blood
is in fact acidic is melted through
several floors which we see demonstrate
here once more the area is safe and the
next part of the movie was suddenly a
Cameron was in-depth on during his
masterclass session as they come in we
can see that they tried to barricaded or
shirt and in the movie novelization the
entrances were all covered by tractors
they discover face huggers and jaws and
we get some lines that subtly hint
towards Burke's plan
looks like love at first sight to me
oh he likes you Berg
is of course trying to use the aliens
for profit and he's very much on their
side in many ways the first alien film
of course had the Twister Ash was a
Villain 2 and Bishop is suspected to be
a villain in this what about Cameron
subverts Expectations by making the
hidden threat a human and Burke remains
one of the best buddies in the franchise
I think now later on he tries to use his
face hookers on Newton Ripley in order
to smuggle Xenomorphs back to Earth they
of course would need to which we get
foreshadowed in this line here two are
alive the rest are dead an alien there
was also the fear that removing a face
hugger could kill the host and this is
confirmed by Bishop here discussing one
of the procedures surgically removed
before embryo implantation subject
matter John Jay died during the
procedure the Marines then move further
into the compound after the motion
detector goes off again Cameron frame it
so that we were looking at them so that
we couldn't see what they were moving
into they willingly walked towards a
danger due to their hubris Razz Ripley
hangs back because she knows what the
danger is if we look at her face she's
the only one who seems afraid but this
changes when we learn it's a little girl
and not a xenomorph Newt runs out and in
a nice subtle touch that you only really
catch in slow motion if you watch Hicks
moving Drake's gun out the way so that
he misses as he fires in the master
class Cameron also talked about how this
changes the Dynamics of the scene as we
go from fearful to curious after we see
it's not a threat Ripley then squats
down and we get a close-up of her face
which is when we watch her eyes move
about and as a lock continued we cut to
what she's seeing this is the first big
reveal in this segment and it's just
subtly building upon what we've talked
about before and we find she's created
her own little man cave that looks like
your room when you are 15. as Hadley's
hope is deemed safe everything opens up
including Newt after being a mute this
happens because Ripley actually treats
her like a human and whereas the Marines
ignore her Ripley actually cares about
her she asks about her family and
brother and like Ripley we learn that
she's now completely on her own
mirroring the examination in the first
film we see Bishop carrying out one on
the face again and Ash was of course
fascinated with it too Ash thought it
was the perfect organism and to do a
nice little play on that by having him
say it's magnificent again it's meant to
make us suspect something is off and
this all comes before the big actions
seen in the hero's journey we see how
the pipes of the factory have turned
into the spinal column bones of the
xenomorph and it transforms the
industrial landscape into something more
alien and crafting the original film HR
Geiger wanted to create something
biomechanical and we which machines
seemingly Blended in with the flesh
that's definitely the case here with the
characters very much traveling into the
abyss in Campbell's Heroes Journey this
typically happens at the midpoint and
it's what triggers a transformation in
the main character now after learning
that firing the guns will create a
thermonuclear explosion the Marines are
left with their hands tied behind their
backs although Hicks keeps his shotgun
and we get the infamous line that's been
used across a number of different things
I'd like to keep this handy
Close Encounters
for Close Encounters this letter comes
to be true as a xenomorph almost gets
Hicks but he uses the shotgun to kill it
now he came across a woman who's about
to give birth to his anymore of which we
showed before with the Kill Me scene
this is very much Ripley's stream coming
true and in this subtle moment we see
Sigourney grab her chest in order to
display this it's then revealed that the
Xenomorphs are very much embedded into
the walls and also the ceilings Scott
set the trend for this and the nostrama
was purposely filled with pipes and
crevices that resembled the creature
everything goes to hell and Ripley goes
from a passive to an active character
after she takes control of the APC this
is the beginning of her transformation
in the hero's journey that makes her
start to face her fears rather than
letting them control her at this point
Ripley drives through the Factory and
there's a chance that you might
recognize his place this is actually the
same location that Batman drove the
Batmobile through at the end of the 1989
film which two ended up blowing up like
how this place eventually does the score
thumps away and this was composed by
James Horner in just three weeks but now
playing podcast went over it in depth
and I definitely recommend you give them
a listen as I check them out before
making these videos and they're filled
to the brim with trivia apparently
Horner was furious with Cameron because
he kept sending him New Visions of the
Final Cut due to him constantly changing
his mind he hired a Lovejoy to put
together the film who'd been the editor
on a number of Stanley Kubrick films
Cameron loved them however he realized
Lovejoy had developed quite a slow paced
style whilst working with Kubrick which
Cameron ended up feeling was the wrong
fit for this movie so they had to redo
it several times and this meant that
Horner was constantly working away
redoing things which led to some bad
blood between them Horner said he'd
never work with him again however he did
end up doing the scores for Titanic in
Avatar after the pass moved things out I
think he can kind of tell some of these
bits were done quickly though as at
points it sounds identical the Horner's
work on Wrath of Khan
[Music]
thank you
here it comes now
[Music]
foreign
just reuse stuff I guess but you know
what even with all that I think the
score is still excellent for the film
now they make it out and we hear that
some of the vital signs and the soldiers
are still ticking these were people that
were captured in cocooned and held in
place that more Xenomorphs could be
created outside we see that the planet
isn't as harsh as it was in the first
film and news father at the start of the
movie went out without wearing a space
suit in the first film The the search
team had it on them but this shows how
terraforming has made the planet now
more hospitable now at the drop ship we
get one of my favorite moments with the
xenomorph attacking I just love the way
that it sneaks up behind Colette it
starts shaking away almost like
shivering like it's so full of rage and
just I imagine peering back at this
you'd absolutely crap your buds now as
it crashes rear projection was used here
and it feels like a massive gut punch
watching it brought down game over man
this game over yes again that and I tell
you what we better start wrapping up the
breakdown now because most don't drop
likes mostly you're enjoying the video
though helps the channel out with a crap
joke and we appreciate it now back at
the main Hub we watch as the Shadows go
up once more juxtaposing how they opened
up before and this shows how lost the
group are they're pretty much going for
the same plan that doomed The Colony and
I love Bill Paxton this moment as he
gets all the best lines as he turns into
a bumbling wreck 17 days
hey man I don't want to rain on your
parade we're not going to last 17 hours
this little girl survived longer than
that with no weapons and no training
right
[Music]
why don't you put her in charge and the
director's cut they arm some Auto
cannons that will kill anything that
moves and they seal themselves in even
blocking up the same bunch of boxes that
we saw didn't work before it's a pretty
crap plan but it's all I have it
actually shows the intelligence of these
animals the idea was that the one on the
Nostromo was only alive for 24 hours and
this is why it was far more Primal these
however away Smarter with a queen even
having intelligence that Rivals a human
Ripley nurtures Newt and the pair talk
about nightmares and Ripley's daughter
being dead it's where the Hammers harm
the idea that she has to protect Newt so
that she doesn't lose another
quote-unquote daughter at this point
they discuss the eggs face huggers and
question what it is that's length name
Hudson figures out that they operate
similar to a beehive with a queen
working at the center of them originally
in this scene they were going to talk
about how this xenomorph separated and
we were gonna learn that the tail
actually came with a stinger that
paralyzed its victims this was gonna be
one why the Stinger went up Lambert's
trousers in the first film and it was a
technique that they used to subdue their
prey later on in the film they were
going to have developed the neurotoxin
that candidates and Anthony was taken
Hicks and Ripley were gonna inject
themselves with it they would then wake
up on the other side in the hive which
is how they were going to save Newt and
then Escape either way we get what we
get and Ripley confronts Burke after
Bishop says he wants to bring back two
living face hookers his hand is played
slightly here as he reveals that he
wants to slip them past quarantine
completely undetected do you really
think you can get a dangerous organism
like that past ICC quarantine how can
they impound it if they don't know about
it they wouldn't know because Ripley and
Newt would have embryos inside of them
and wanting to kill a woman and kid is
pretty despicable now he tries to talk
Ripley into letting him bring the
embryos back because they'd be set for
life new course was a promise news
father a big share it's a Faustian deal
that won't work out for Ripley and he
manages to see through it instantly they
end up sending Bishop up the pipe in one
of the most claustrophobic scenes ever
and in the build up to this they did
talk about how bad this deal was but you
know what I'd be cramped like Lemmy
Wings to get away from the aliens a hit
shows ripped his gun and not like that
mate and Gorman wakes up which is when
Burke launches his attack Ripley goes in
a nice room to find her asleep on the
floor and this ends up saving the pair's
life hiding behind a blanket she likely
would have done this in order to survive
and being hidden explains why the
Facehugger doesn't attack them until
they wake up it all goes down where they
do with Burke turning off the Monitor
and I guess in space no one can hear you
scream she signals the Alarm by setting
a fire and after getting a little too
close for comfort they reveal the truth
about Burke however before he can be
brought to Justice the Xenomorphs swore
men and we once more get an amazing
motion tracker scene where we can't see
what's coming in but we know that it is
there's an amazing reveal with events
and we catch them climbing upside down
which leads to a big standoff guess how
they filmed this up up just turned the
camera around it's VFX master class now
bear clocks himself in a room but he's
eventually given a villain's death with
him coming face to face with a xenomorph
now a deleted scene that isn't in the
director's cut actually revealed his
true fate and we learned that he
survived Ripley came across him in the
hive and he was strung up on a wall
screaming about how bad the pain in his
chest was Ripley gave him a grenade and
she carried on which was kind of a mercy
killing that's probably better than he
deserves and I think they cut it because
of how Vasquez and Gorman go at slowly
the grouper picked off one by one with
Hudson going down be for the other two
are killed with an explosive is then
seen some what mirrors the one from the
first movie and with Newt knowing the
way she's able to lead them through it
whether the explosion throws her into a
gear which then drops it down and she's
grabbed by his xenomorph this is a
brilliant shot with a coming up behind
her in the water and it's probably one
of the most horrifying images in the
film honestly I I kind of think that the
injection thing we talked about before
would have worked better because Ripley
and Hicks both know that she'll be kept
alive but they're still like [__] them
kids uh to be fair Ripley of course goes
back and she decides to save her even
after Bishop Lance he tells her that
they have 26 minutes left and at this
point it's actually 26 minutes until the
movie ends now from here Ripley descends
into the nest and it's almost like a
journey through the nine circles of hell
this shows how much he's grown from the
first film even though the two climaxes
share similar beats the first movie had
a Ripley returning for the cat Jonesy
and in the end she ended up running away
yeah Ripley does the same thing but
she's prepared and going towards a
danger instead of just trying to get
away we see her arming up and even get a
woman count down by Saba that's become a
cliche in movies you now have 15 minutes
to reach minimum same distance now this
is actually a call back to mother and
motherhood is of course a theme in this
movie so it makes sense why they brought
it in here now we very much get the
heroes shot as she steps in and from
here we see his Ripley descends through
the factory desperately searching for
Newt eventually she gets it and they
actually use the dummy for most of this
so that Sigourney was able to carry her
alongside the gun we have the surrogate
child in one arm and a weapon in the
other and it's such a cool image that it
was used for the poster now the alien
queen moment was another thing that
Cameron talked about in his master class
he watches the location starts to blow
up around Ripley she runs as fast as she
can but then walks into somewhere that
makes her stop again the cameras put it
at her rather than watching is looking
at and as an audience Were Meant to
pause and wonder what it is that's made
her stop amongst all this Carnage
Cameron said that the idea for this
actually came to him in a dream and
during that he ran into a room got to
the center of it and then realized he
was surrounded by wasps he knew he
couldn't get at a door before they got
to him and it just made him stand still
completely unable to move the whole
point of this moment is for us to go
from one extreme to the other we watch
his Ripley girls from sprinting through
the area to then standing still the
explosions initially took over the Sound
Stage but they're then silenced when
Ripley realizes what's going on
[Music]
now this provides an altered state of
awareness and the camera goes from 24 to
48 frames per second so it can
transition into slow motion this moment
is almost completely silent as well
until we hear the eggs being laid and we
get the slow reveal of the queen as we
follow Ripley's eye line This pulls up
very much to reveal its throne with the
creatures sat in the middle of it it's
like nothing we've ever seen before and
to this day this is the biggest puppet
ever put on film it's what got Stan
Winston the job on Jurassic Park and to
me it's the coolest creature in the
entire franchise Cameron said that this
very much leads into a negotiation which
keeps things tense but it also gives
Ripley a reason of how she got out of
there however the queen goes back in it
and we see an egg opening up which makes
Ripley burn the entire area in a
cathartic moment we see her just
standing there shooting away until she
runs out of bullets and then when that's
done she switches over to the grenades
reminds me a lot of a video game when
You Face a boss character and you just
keep shooting them and switching guns
until you're out of ammo it's such a
great scene that leads into the final
Chase is Ripley desperately races out
there with Newt it all goes to hell with
a queen pursuing Ripley through the
corridors until I left comes again I
think this inspired a lot of games
whether you having to survive until your
exit arrives Resident Evil I'm looking
at you what about with it comes another
elevator for the queen which follows
Ripley up there we get a great fake out
where she thinks her Bishop is left here
and an amazing reveal of the queen
coming out of the darkness Bishop saves
them though and originally the novel had
it saying that Rippy was gonna throw
herself in the over the edge instead of
them being killed by the queen that's
how desperate it was and that's probably
another reason why I feel so uplifting
when they finally make it out of there
everything seems like it's gonna be
A-Okay but on board the ship we see the
alien queen has a surprise blood drips
down and melts the floor and Bishops
ripped in half just after Ripley says
that he did okay described as the [__]
versus [__] fight not by me that's
sexist we see his replicas head to head
with a queen leading to a major Showdown
and attacks Newton events and we watch
Ripley Dunning the power armor in order
to take it out now originally in this
script things went to the airlock like
how they do here but the Queen's blood
was what caused the hole in the hull
this then sucked her out and this was
also something that was used in Alien
Resurrection well that the whole point
of this movie is to take Ripley from
being a passive character into an active
one and this is why she has to be the
one who opens the airlock the queen is
sucked out and they should have her
going into space was later referenced in
Infinity War when they killed ebony
Moore Peter Parker even asked Tony if
he'd seen that really old movie Aliens
and he used the same technique to take
him out as Ripley climbs back in newt
says
and she finally gets a Redemption from
being unable to get back to her daughter
who watches bishop and Hicks are sealed
off and Ripley goes to sleep with Newt
next to her too bringing things full
circle from end of the first movie that
closes out the film and they of course
did have a sequel in mind which is
teased at the end though they never knew
which way they would take things we can
hear the opening of an egg SAC at the
end of the credits
anyway that closes out the movie and
what an incredible film it is but my
entire life I've always had alieners
being my favorite out of the two but
after doing this breakdown I'm not so
sure anymore I forgot how dense that the
film was and when you compare the run
times of this in my last video I know
there's gonna be a big difference ask me
another day and I might say that this is
my favorite but either way I think this
is a perfect movie Alien probably stuck
with me more because of how much it
scared me as a kid and I can remember
the first time I saw that whereas I
can't with this however ignoring that
scarring on my childhood judge on its
own merits I think this is probably
better it works as an amazing Sequel and
Cameron massively Builds on the first
movie to create an arc for Ripley that
makes her face up to her fears this
movie even just kind of crafted what the
archetype of a sequel should be and
whenever we're discussing sequels these
days we say it has to be bigger and
better that's what Cameron did but he's
done it without it feeling like it's
cheap things like the alien queen take
elements of the first film and it
evolves them to their eventuality that
makes sense I think there's a reason
that the queen hasn't been top when it
comes to the Xenomorphs it's the next
step up an absolutely terrifying in
every single way now not only does this
film build on the first movie as well
but it also manages to actually change
genres and take the franchise into being
an action movie it's something others
would mimic and I think games like Dead
Space 2 Metroid the entire Resident Evil
franchise they all owe a hell of a lot
to this film the movie changed Cinema
and I hope you've had as good of a time
going back through it as I have for this
video I really think this is Cameron's
best movie or well this or maybe
Terminator 2 but off the back of this
the franchise remained one of the Sci-Fi
genres best even if everything after it
was pretty met or bad it shows just how
strong this film is that we're still
riding off the back of this nearly 40
years later and I forgot just how much
that I actually love it now Predator was
rushed in the production off the back of
this with that and its sequel arriving
before Ripley's return in Alien 3. that
happened six years later and whether
that was for better or worse is another
conversation but in the end I think
these first two movies are absolutely
outstanding it's rare you get two
Classics back to back like this and for
me it's up there with the first two
Godfather films in terms of them both
being incredible so yeah one of the best
films ever made and obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on it so make sure
you comment below and let me know anyway
that wraps up the video and make sure
you check out our breakdown of alien
which will be linked on screen right now
huge thank you for sitting until the end
of Paul you've been the best and if you
want me to see Alien 3 make sure you
comment below thank you peace hopefully
not don't you dare comment me I'm not
watching alien 3.